there is a nod to full house the show
um and it's it
i was very excited to do it we are an
unusual couple
oh i don't think that was ever in
question
we just don't know what to expect okay
so i have to say when i sat down to
watch
um the episodes that that we were given
i
didn't expect what i saw i thought it
was so cool i wonder for you
what it was like shooting you know in
this completely different way
in the sitcom kind of way and shooting
in front of a live audience especially
for that first episode
yeah the first episode was um definitely
like a
full thrust into sitcom land with having
the audience there and
having two days to shoot an episode um
you know is is something that i've never
experienced in my life
um and it was really fun
and it was a great way to to start
our our ensemble at that moment
there's a lot of adrenaline and um
it was it was really fun and this whole
show
it has been a joy because it's
there's not a lot of opportunities like
this show out in the world
um so as an actor it was uh it was
so wild and fun to to really lean into
all of these
um these different decades through
american
sitcoms i have to say i love the way you
look in that 50s uh you know era sitcom
yeah i think you fit right into that
aesthetic
there's certain part of it that you like
the fashion maybe the
you know the voice that you use yes
the voice was the voices i rest in a
very like low
chesty register and that is um was not
right for the american sitcom so there's
a lot of vocal warm-ups that have to be
done
and um i do enjoy the mannerisms and the
femininity
of it because um i think that's always
fun
for me because i'm just kind of like
like a clumsy i don't know masculine
woman or something and um
it's really fun for me to be very um
effeminate it was um it was it was very
new and nice and felt fun yeah i like
seeing you do physical comedy i thought
it was really fun
it was very fun um so we know that we
kind of get to see
you guys go through the decade so you
know i have to ask is there any chance
we could get like a
full house moment a nod to your sister's
uh work there is a there is a nod to
full house the show
um and it's it
i was very excited to do it
it was very it was very meta what is
that meta moment like when you have
when you have that yeah it was just
surreal and i think that
filming in front of a live studio
audience is also
very surreal because um i have such
old early memories of of
being on the audience side and it felt
so comfortable like when i remember it
felt so comfortable as a child
and here i was doing something that felt
so um foreign as an actor
um and then matt shakman our director he
was a child sitcom actor
not only did he direct them but he was a
child sitcom actor so on our back lot
he was telling us stories from like him
skateboarding
as a kid filming on those back lots
and it's just there's in the katherine
hahn's first job i believe was
was a sitcom a multi-cam
and so they're all we all had these
moments
at certain times where we all felt so
strange and like
just in love with the job we were we
were on
so i'm a marvel head so it all like kind
of made sense to me but i wonder
um viewers out there that may not have
seen like all
23 marvel movies or you know will they
have to binge them do you think or can
you come into it and
feel like you're okay like you know
i think this is an ex an experience
where people
can come in with fresh eyes
i really think that if you're just in it
for the ride and you kind of know that
everyone's
that people are superheroes and um you
know you can extend your imagination to
what that
then means um it's just kind of a fun
ride and
all answers itself within the show um
and so i think anyone could
watch it which is exciting to me because
i think that i think that is
i think we are going to have that
experience with marvel fans
and i feel like we might have a few
first-timers out there so i
i'm excited to hear those experiences if
there are first-timers who want to cram
before they watch this what is your best
tip
in cramming marvel movies then to come
into this
well if it's just specific for our show
i think all they really have to watch is
the ones with paul and eyes
that's as simple as that just
just avengers movies that's it
well baby should throw in you know an
iron man and uh
you gotta watch that first one to kind
of understand first iron man to
understand like what's really going on
here
yeah i love it um so um
you know we've had such a crazy 2020 and
now 2021 hasn't given us much of a
reprieve
yet but you know there's still this big
question about the future of
blockbusters
because we're in such um unprecedented
time
we're really thankful for all the new
content that we're getting
um right now in whatever form that we're
gonna get it
but what do you think um about this
whole new normal
rollouts and i mean one of the things i
love so much is going to see a big tent
pole in the in the movie theater
i'm missing um also art house films a
lot
um the last movie i saw was um
a portrait of a lady on fire in theaters
before
the lockdown and um it was phenomenal
and um it makes me worried
um that we're not going to
that if everything becomes saturated
over all the streaming services
um then we we might lose the opportunity
of
being surprised and
i feel like i feel like art house cinema
i just don't know where it goes after
after this and um blockbusters as well
because they rely on that
on that income to keep making them
before i leave you i gotta ask about
catherine han cause that lady is pure
comedy
so how much fun did you have with her
i am so in love with catherine han um
i am so grateful that i
got to have her in my life for the last
year um
she is so funny humor is just a part of
every bone in her body and she's just
so talented and filled with so
much acting gloriousness
and um i have loved
working with catherine beyond and i love
that tiana calls you lizzy i think
that's so cute oh yeah
i think most people call me lizzie
though oh yes tiana
we had a great i had a great time with
town i'm such a fan of hers
um as an actor before she joined us and
and this was an amazing opportunity to
kind of
set her off on the next um marvel
adventure she'll have
of course well thank you so much i
appreciate it i think this is really
innovative and i can't wait till
it's all rolled out thank you all right
thanks